okay [ __ ] for back no race what what
you don't like me because you think that
I am an addict what no what are you
talking about computing I wait boy I am
his mental I am so proud of you what do
you mean a mint don't worry about that
okay so what you got for James de Santa
some kids he's already late on his
payments and I have this bad feeling
that he will do more damage to the car
then we can get back from him in the
exhibit and interest rate payments yeah
sure just go and get it the house is on
halsted her off eclipse it's an SUV some
rockford hills daddy's boy nonsense
don't worry about it start to bring back
a thousand good condition a scotch don't
worry about it's so good to see you my
boy hey good luck in there a law school
like an Oscar
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you suck the
decals are on fire
ok let's look at this pocket car
yeah [ __ ]
anyway let you change your mind when I
discover that you betray me perhaps I
hear you took the bike for yourself my
employee of the man was some time a meal
worms don't get that back to da oh I am
sure you will get this cut off that that
is boy and then we talk insurance papers
say they have a locked garage so you'll
need to gain access from inside the
house man is never easy with you is
Jimmy do not talk to me about easy you
see you [ __ ]
[ __ ] let me a mighty out
ok finally way into the house
chitosan i pass house
can't find it
oh yes I can
we start and climb this door
yeah [ __ ]
how I get in here [ __ ] a lock [ __ ] cuz
you have a massive deeper fish Oh chef
this is getting insane i don't think i
have a piece like a knife attack me no
one creeps on the stage off my [ __ ]
family dig
your waist is demon [ __ ]
daddy [ __ ] idiot I still love him
though sort of what the other day I
walked in on him all over pictures of my
friends [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you're real from stands a real pro now
you're a great student I just loosen up
those hips okay like this yeah loosen
them up there what oh my [ __ ] am i doing
okay Amanda now just follow through ah
there we it you know that swallow
there we go
yeah [ __ ] it's on talking about
robbery and a life I Simeon I got to
ride man I'm coming back yeah if you
actually believe every possession to me
this time I can have it back out on the
street before the day is done share that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's a 90 semi-automatic pushed
against your skull look around just keep
driving where you're going
I come on man it was a repo job Stiles
behind on this [ __ ] note unlikely
considering my son just got the car and
look at it the way you're going about
this I guess you're working a credit
fraud Oh credit rob a serious dude I
just worked the [ __ ] repo I
appreciate a kid who follows orders
without taking responsibility yeah maybe
one day we'll have a beer and I'll
explain how the world really works who
gives you the slip a corgi dog by the
name of Simeon you carry this
businessman you look legit to you look
man didn't just between him and you'll
[ __ ] song don't worry me and mr. yet
Terry Oh Lord this out that's the place
yeah this looks like me Oh drive into
right through the [ __ ] window at fast
prop with two rounds of back to your
skull and do it myself and then you
can't be for real I look like a [ __ ]
joke to you man [ __ ] my life man [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] insane
do it
yeah Franklin what the [ __ ] are you
doing mr. Sammy it's not exactly hard
looks like Alex Trump big for job well
done I get out of your kid you mother
[ __ ] I won't be treated like
you like that [ __ ] you recognize this
car I it look like it's worth five grand
a month of you you [ __ ] racist I'm
Tyson this thing's gonna need serious
body work for it's worth five grand a
month he agree to a violent thing I have
his signature yeah the he agree to have
some fun break into my [ __ ] house I
have fun I can I be a [ __ ] idiot but
you are fraudulent scumbag piece don't
make me have to come back here
that's [ __ ] up
ok
the guy's awesome
thanks for watching the off thank you